what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the latest exciting
developments in a demon slayer if you
enjoyed the insider content on this
channel and want to see more make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bells to actually
get notified when you demon slayer
videos come out if that ain't enough
demons are content you can follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime out
drawer for more including crucial
updates there will be manga spoilers in
this video you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
the last video I made about chapter 174
did amazing so I just want to thank you
for the awesome feedback on that one in
this video we're gonna be talking about
chapter 175 where we got the conclusion
of one of the most exciting battles yet
in demon slayer as you guys will
remember it was only around the last
chapter where the pillars and Renia
began to turn the tables of the fight
the fight has been going on for many
chapters and demon moon one kakushi bow
was absolutely flexing on everyone
throughout most of the match however
recently go me the rock pillar got a hit
on kuku she bows right arm taking it off
completely this led to a chain of
important events Muccino stabbed cuckoo
sheba with his sword and ganya shot him
with his flesh bullets the bullets enter
kuku she was body and tree roots began
growing from his body and trapping him
now trapped he had three of the
strongest pillars attacking him at once
he had a life flash before his eyes
experienced his life felt threatened to
the core and his body froze up this was
something he hadn't felt since his
little brother the breath of the Sun
user almost killed him 400 years ago
before his brother Yuri she could finish
him off he died standing up of old age
just like fellow epic old guy white
beard from one piece and just like white
beard good Ichi will go down as one of
the most epic old guys in anime history
but anyways that brings us to the
current chapter koko she will knows that
if his little brother had taken just one
more breath he would have ended his life
in a split second you would eat she
overpowered him by that much he could
have sliced his head off in just one
breath I told you guys last time that I
found it strange that you each he did
slice Koko's Evil's neck once but
somehow he didn't kill him combine this
with the fact that you're reaching cried
before fighting his brother and
me it seems like your DG couldn't bring
himself to kill his brother even though
he did become a demon knowing his level
of skill duty she could have cut off
kakushi bull's head the first time but
he did it however Coco's evil thinks he
only survived because your li-chee
happened to die one breath before he was
gonna kill him instead of Kaku Shiva
being like hey this is awesome I'm alive
even though he could have killed me
kuku she will actually feels disgraced
so I think we can safely say this demon
moon is a glass half empty kind of guy
all this time he's been living with the
shame of only surviving because of luck
he believes that because of the way
things ended with his brother there's no
longer a chance for an honorable death
for him props go to your Ichi for being
solar powered and he can completely
traumatize an opponent for life by
simply showing them the difference
between their skill levels Coco Chabot
as I expected confirmed that your ichi
was the strongest demon slayer in
history after his little brother passed
away Coco Chabot had chosen to keep
winning UNIF it meant quote-unquote that
hideous form so we go back to the
present muy Chino is stabbing Coco
Chabot yo me and Santa me are about to
reach him and Coco's evil roars he
launches crescent-shaped attacks in all
directions this attack not only frees
him from the tree roots but also since
the pillars flying backwards sana me and
yo may do a pretty good job of dodging
but ganya and Muccino seem to take
significant hits Kenya being a demon can
just regenerate probably but I hate
seeing mu Ichiro takes so much damage
Muccino is one of my favorite pillars
he is only 14 yet he's so skilled to put
this in perspective sanam is 21 and Yomi
is 27 mu Ichiro can already access the
see-through world he was able to flex on
upper moon 5 and he managed to stab kuku
she bows body however he previously lost
an arm and the leg and now he received a
deep cut through the middle of his body
unlike Kenya he can't just regenerate
and he even talks about dying in this
chapter which really worries me perhaps
he's just too Opie at too young and age
and the mangaka thought that he had to
be nerfed somehow but no matter what I
really don't want him to die kuku she
will reveals what appears to be that
hideous form here
to earlier in this form he has sword
blades like the one he wields coming out
all over his body
he's like a samurai porcupine hybrid at
this point the fact that he has used
this form shows that the pillars and
ganya together were strong enough to
force him to use every trick he has he's
no longer that calm Kakashi Bo who felt
like he could handle them all with one
normal blade even though he enters his
sword porcupine form Muccino being the
boss that he is still stubbornly manages
to keep his sword lodge into Kakashi
bows body despite the fact that his
lower body appears to be completely cut
off it appears that in this form Coco
Shiro can launch attacks without
swinging his sword thus it seems like
the tables have quickly turned back
CooCoo she will seems to have the upper
hand again Muccino with one arm and only
his upper body decides that help protect
everyone he doesn't want to like do me
and Sanne me die because they are needed
in the final fight against moves on mu
Ichiro has to protect them he knows he
has to do something before he dies and
through sheer willpower and some anime
magic he finds away his blade the one
that's still inside demon moon one
starts turning red the same color that
your Ricci's blade was even though he
shouldn't even be alive after all the
damage he's taken mu Ichigo is such a
boss that he stuck it out long enough
for a miracle to take place the red
blade causes koku she bows body to
stiffen and it makes his insides feel
like they're on fire
since you're Ichi the breath of the Sun
user had a red blade it seems like the
red blade may be associated with the Sun
or Sun powers as we know the Sun is
super effective against demons and most
will die if they're exposed to it except
for Nezu code the chosen one it's kind
of like a vampire thing where the Sun
will pretty much cause them to be burned
alive the fact that the red blade has
such a powerful effect on Kakashi Bo the
demon moon and makes his insides feel
like they're on fire leaves me to
believe that in some way the breath of
the Sun the original breath is
manifesting inside mu cheetos blade the
red blade initially stopped kagoshima in
his tracks it seems to partially
paralyzed him so he can't properly
respond to the pillar attacks both sana
me and Yomi are close by with their
weapon
well half of Kenya's body is lying on
the floor and watching what's going on
CooCoo she was so focused on the strong
pillars in front of him that he's
forgotten about Kenya
again kenya still has his flesh bullets
inside kuku she bows body then he uses
his demon arts and more tree roots begin
to grow out of Coco she bows body if mu
Ichiro's red blade soul Coco's she bow
down before
Kenya's tree roots further root him in
place kuku Sheba notices what's
happening he plans to kill Kenya so that
he can put an end to these annoying
roots once and for all
but his attack won't come out Propst
Agana for again successfully distracting
kakushi bow while kuku she was
distracted by kenya yo may takes
advantage of this opening and brings his
iron spike ball straight down a Coco she
bows neck so right now we have muchos
red blades slowing Coco she bow down
we have Kenya's roots slowing him down
even more and we have Gil made the
strongest pillar bringing his heavy
weapon down on the demons head yet Coco
Shiva's neck is still too tough yo may
decides to bring the axe and of his
chain up so that he can apply pressure
on both sides of Coco she bows neck and
hopefully get his head to come off
however cuckoo she bow blocks gomez axe
with his sword
Kaku Shiva points out that Kenya's tree
roots are growing by drinking his demon
blood and they're keeping his techniques
from coming out props to ganya who was
way more useful in this battle than I
expected him to be he took full
advantage of being underestimated and
unleash one of the most effective
techniques we've seen on a demon so far
not only does it help trap the demon in
question it also seems to seal their
power on the other hand Coco SIBO notes
that Mui Cheetos red pinch sword is
causing pain and making his body
extremely stiff the red blade makes him
think of your Ichi because as I
mentioned before your DG also had a red
blade that's when we get into yet
another flashback in the past kakushi
Belasco's brother here - Ichi when they
were younger about a successor he asked
you - Ichi who he had planned to replace
him after he was dead Coco Shiva was
arrogant he said nobody can compare to
us trying to pass on our breath arts is
hopeless the techniques that we have
mastered will just be lost and
quote ironically despite the fact that
he's much more gifted than kakushi bow
your knee she is also more humble URI
she says that neither of them are as
great as Coco she was making them seem
he puts things in perspective he says
and I quote we are but a line in the
long long book of human history even as
we speak the voices of those who will
surpass us cry out for the first time
they will find a way to the same place
again no matter when the curtain closes
on our lives we can rest easy what is
there to worry about it's an
exhilarating feeling right brother and
quote as he's saying this Julie she has
a gentle smile on his face he is a great
example of a stoic he is at peace he
knows how to put things in perspective
he knows that death is nothing to fear
and that life will go on even after he
passes away there is nothing to worry
about
he's also wearing the earrings that have
become so familiar to us by this point
then we jump back to the present and
sunny is rushing at koku she bow he
smashes his blade into Guillaume a
spiked ball the weapons begin to turn
red like muay cheetos blade and they
finally break through Kakashi bows tough
neck
all the while superimposed onto these
events are your each's words where he's
saying and I quote that Sunday children
will be born into this world and they
will surpass us to go on to new heights
on towards the summit and quote on the
last page we see the cuckoo she bows
head has finally come off now I wouldn't
say that any of these guys have
surpassed Coco she was level let alone
your reaches level yet at least
individually what is very satisfying
about this fight if this is in fact the
end of it is that everyone played a
crucial role in combined they were able
to surpass Coco Chabot Moochie rose
stiffened his movements with his red
blade Kenya took away his techniques
with his flesh bullets
Yomi brought his powerful iron ball down
on his head and sanam he brought his
blade down on the iron ball giving it
enough power to take off the demons head
after being built up so much some people
might want to complain about Coco Shiva
being beaten but I think the mangaka did
it in a good way
this battle has actually been going on
for many many chapters so it's not like
oka Sheba was easily beaten plus three
of us
strongest pillars and ganya with his
extremely useful flesh bullets were all
100% necessary for the final victory
this seems to be the end of this fight
and if it is I am satisfied with the way
it wrapped up you can't say that Koko
Cibo didn't put up a good fight
nevertheless I will allow for the
possibility that it might not be over
yet
just because upper moon three Akasa
could regrow his head so why not upper
moon one who is supposed to be much more
powerful albeit the fact that he has a
red tinge blade and flesh bullets inside
him make interact the possibility of
head regeneration let me know what you
think in the comments is it all over for
this legendary breath of the Moon user a
lot of you were saying in the last video
that you thought congedo would show up
to fico Khushi bow but we were
previously told by kyria Ubu Isshiki
that Tangela needs to head over to Musa
and that the three pillars and ganya
would succeed in defeating Kakashi bow
it seems at this point that he was right
and that we won't get to see times your
FICO Khushi bow but that's fine since
the battle against Mouzon is sure to be
even more epic we'll see what happens
from here on out but it really seems
like this could be the end game upper
moons who lived for centuries are
dropping like flies even the strongest
ones and the story is clearly leading up
to a showdown with moose on the main
antagonist of the series since the
beginning of the show obviously the
mangaka may figure out a way to prolong
the story just like black clover did
after the devil was defeated but if the
mangaka wanted to it definitely seems
like the story could end soon I hope not
though this is one of my favorite series
right now and I would hate to see it end
anyways that's it for this one thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed it
be sure to smash that like button to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you actually get notified when u
Dimas air videos come out for even more
Demon Slayer updates and content follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar a big thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons don't want an only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
king saud rest angel Cruz Steelers poet
Pablo
and atropos race and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephen and Radha al-hola attempt
Matty Mac 239 and makoto-kun if you
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon calm an Emir
or and becoming a patron today for as
little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these pillars right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patriotic column slash
anime out drawer link in the description
if you're interested you can also now
join the YouTube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer
you'll still get the same awesome
rewards no matter where you decide to
support us anyways thanks so much for
everything and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]